Pathogens have been evolving with their hosts for a very long time,
and in the process they have come up with just about every trick in the book to
evade or suppress the host defenses.
In this lecture,
we're going to look at how they can evade by very eating their surface
properties.
This is done by viruses,
bacteria,
and by you carry out like plasmodium and Trent Inter Panis Ohms.
They can hide inside the genome.
That's what retroviruses do.
They can hide inside cells,
which is what a plasmodium,
the malaria pathogen,
the trypanosomes Toxoplasma,
mycobacterium,
listeria,
all of these are pathogens that actually hide inside the host cell and they can
also suppress the host immune system by disrupting it's function by producing
proteins,
by blocking intracellular defenses,
by slowing down the recruitment of immune cells,
by and by killing immune cells.
So viruses can suppress the immune system.
They do it by inhibiting humoral immunity,
and that's done with by disrupting sensors.
So some of the viruses that do this or herpes simplex,
Cytomegalo virus and Vaccinium,
they can inhibit inflammatory responses by disrupting cytokines and cell
adhesion.
So they play with the hosts signaling system.
This is done by an vaccinium Myxoma,
the Epstein Barr Virus,
which causes infectious mononucleosis and several cancers.
Okay.
They can block antigen processing by inhibiting gene expression and peptide
transport.
That's done by herpes simplex and cytomegalovirus.
Yeah.
And they can immunol suppressed the host with mimics of interleukins.
Epstein Barr virus does this.
They can also disrupt the cytoplasmic sensors,
the viral RNA.
And that's done by payroll mixo viruses,
which include the agents that cause mumps and measles.
So viruses have a pretty diverse repertoire of methods of suppressing the host
immune system.
Yeah.
Many bacteria can vary their surface properties by miss paring,
simple sequence repeat.
So these are sequences that are involved in genes that are expressing cells that
are found on the surfaces of bacteria.
And if they simply can vary by adding or deleting the number of nucleotides in
the sequence,
they will be producing DNA of different lengths that will then be causing
different a triplet codes to be produced for the proteins.
Yeah.
Here are some of the phenotypic consequences.
You can think of these as being molecules upon the surface.
So for example,
this box here is for salic acid that can be added or dropped.
Gal is a galactose that can be added or dropped.
Pc is a phosphatidylcholine that can be added or dropped and lick one a.
Those are genes that mediate the attachment of these ligands.
And what you see is that the bacteria,
a single bacteria with a single genome can produce quite an array of different
surfaces.
And these are the surface molecules that the antibodies from the host immune
system are binding to.
So basically what it's doing,
is it switching it's coat?
Yeah.
Some bacteria hide inside host cells.
For example,
Listeria Monocytogenes,
which causes listeriosis moves from macrophage,
the macrophage without emerging into the extracellular environment.
So it's actually hiding inside one of the cells of the immune system.
Toxoplasma Gondii Ai,
which causes toxoplasmosis,
makes assis assist inside,
which it's invisible to the immune system.
Michael bacteria,
which causes leprosy spreads by converting nerve cells to stem cells that then
can invade muscle.
So these are all ways that bacteria use to stay away from the humeral humidity
immunity,
the antibodies and the compliment that are circulating in the blood.
They hide inside cells.
Plasmodium has quite an array of methods of evading.
It's a vertebrate host.
Several stages hide inside cells,
particularly inside red blood cells or inside liver cells.
The mirror zone lights that are out in the blood and therefore subject to attack
very their surface molecules based on illegally polymorphisms and variable
expression from multigene families.
So
they are under attack from opsonizing antibodies.
They're under attack from complement deposition.
They're under attack from invasion blocking antibodies and they,
they're coevolved responds to evade and suppressed is to vary their sequence
while maintaining their function and they have reduced and antigenicity and to
have redundancy in their multigene families,
which allows them to generate these variable surface molecules.
Here is plasmodium hiding in an infected red blood cell.
These red blood cells do not carry MHC class one proteins.
They also lack nuclei.
There is no immune surveillance by cytotoxic t cells.
However,
infected red blood cells are cleared in the spleen where they can be recognized
because infection increases their rigidity.
So the membrane properties of the red blood cell or altered
plasmodium prevents being cleared by inserting a protein called P,
f,
e m p,
one p,
FMP one into the surface of the red blood cells.
Yeah.
And that helps binding to capillaries and it delays passage through the spleen,
but it also mediates cerebral malaria.
So this reaction to getting cleared by the spleen causes a change in the
properties of the red blood cell.
That may also make it more likely to stick the capillaries in the brain.
The host immune system targets Pfe MP one.
So you can see there's a whole series of moves and counter moves going on here.
The pathogen then evades by varying PFE and p one it's coated by Verigenes.
There are about 60 of them in the malaria genome and the plasmodium genome one
very gene is expressed at a time and there's antigenic switching at a rate of
about 2% per infected red blood cell.
So the immune response is out of phase with the parasite that lacks behind.
So this is the log of parasite density here.
Immunity ramps up starts to hit the first one.
The color indicates a switch to the second kind of protein.
It starts to ramp up.
The immune system starts to hit it during the time that the second is ramping
up.
The first one can persist and so forth.
In this way,
the malaria parasite manages to maintain a pretty reasonable density in the
blood.
So it's showing here about log for density in the blood.
Okay.
Another case of varying surface proteins has done by the trypanosomes.
The trypanosomes are you carry oats with a Slingo single flagellum.
Their morphology is categorized according to where you find the [inaudible],
the flagellum attached,
so they're called things like ams to goats,
which lack flagella pro master goats fms to goats,
[inaudible] goats and so forth.
They are exclusively parasitic and they cause three major human diseases,
sleeping sickness,
chagas disease and leishmaniasis.
All pretty nasty diseases.
Yeah,
they also vary their surface protein.
So here is a,
an enhanced photo of a trypanosomes with some red blood cells behind it.
Yeah.
They live extracellularly in the blood where they're subject to attack by the
immune system.
There they are targeted by antibody response.
There's surface is covered with a dense coat of a single protein.
Okay.
And they have variable surface glycoproteins,
so they can vary their surface properties.
This VSG variable surface glycoprotein undergoes frequent genetic modification.
This antigenic variation is what lets the infection survive in the blood and
it's done with cycling.
So the trypanosomes rapidly cycle a protective variant surface protein,
which is their coat.
A single for Panasonic,
has more than 1,500 VSG genes.
Most of them are located in silent arrays and most are pseudo genes.
So this genetic information has to be activated and moved into the right place
to be expressed.
We do not yet understand how the pseudo genes recombine to produce the genes
that encode the functional coats.
Only one variable surface gene is expressed at a time from one of about 15
telomeric VSG expression site transcription units.
So these are moved around in the genome of Japan.
Of Soma,
but exactly what mechanism gets them into position for expression is not yet
known.
Yeah.
Pathogens can also suppress the immune system.
Mycobacterium tuberculosis blocks the fusion of a fake,
a zone with a license zone.
Okay.
Plasmodium sporozoites slow down.
T-Cell recruitment.
Yeah.
Leishmania lives in neutrophils and in dendritic cells and it blocks their
maturation.
It also expresses a protein that disrupts host immune signaling.
So interestingly,
a number of pathogens actually live inside the weapons that the host deploys to
fight them.
They live inside the cells of the immune system.
Okay.
Pathogens from viruses to worms produce enzymes that disrupt immune system,
immune function.
For example,
this is done by Toxoplasma,
which phosphorolates a host resistance protein
and hookworms suppress intestinal proteases and stimulate production of the
immune cells that can reduce inflammation.
Yeah.
Some pathogens also disrupt the immune system with Cystine kinases that are
immunomodulatory.
So these are particularly effective disruptors of immune function.
This method has been converged upon by parasites and pathogens.
Worms,
Meb Leishmania,
plasmodium trypanosomes bacteria and viruses all do this.
The action is to cleave the Immunoglobulin gs,
which are antibodies in blood and lymph to modulate interleukin concentrations
and to control immune cell populations.
So this particular kinase is a particular way of a very effective way of messing
up at least three aspects of immune function.
To summarize,
most pathogens have evolved mechanisms to evade or suppress the immune system.
Some of them vary their surface properties,
some of them hide inside cells or in the genome.
Some of them manipulate cytokine and interleukin signals,
and some of them Cleve antibodies,
some of them actually kill immune cells.
It's a diverse repertoire of countermeasures in this game of move and counter
move.